still the undefeated undisputed
[Music]
[Applause]
in the 1980s Mike Tyson was an absolute
beast in the ring like literally and
figuratively
he didn't just fight people he destroyed
them through the first 25 matches of his
career only 10 people lasted longer than
a single round the average fight time
for everyone else 75 seconds it takes me
longer to toast my English muffin in the
morning and for most of Tyson's
opponents it was longer than any of them
care to be in the ring with him
oh and while Tyson took less than two
minutes to knock out those opponents
it'll take you less than a second hit
subscribe so you can see more videos
like this one anyway he went undefeated
throughout the decade racking up an
astounding 37 straight wins 33 of which
came by way of knockout meaning that
anyone bold enough to challenge Tyson
was essentially digging their own grave
not that Mike Tyson would murder anyone
I don't think I don't know anything
about that I know nothing about numbers
I know what I can do
how about kill this mother okay but
while the toughest human beings on the
planet couldn't take Tyson down there
was still a way for the rest of the
world to stand a fighting chance a way
for all of us to once and for all
bring down the champion
[Applause]
[Music]
now punch out was hardly the first
boxing game to appear on home consoles
before 1987 you had such wonderful games
as this and whatever this is okay so the
early eighties games looked a little bit
more like a broken set of Rock'em
Sock'em robots and real fighters but
that's what made the release of
punch-out all the more impressive
everything that made the original arcade
games so much fun to play carried over
to the home version the colorful
graphics the unique personalities and
overall presentation truly made it stand
out among its contemporaries but what
cemented the game into the collective
consciousness of the gaming world was
its eponymous star Mike Tyson now the
idea to put Tyson into the game came
after Nintendo of America's
then-president minora Arakawa attended a
Tyson fight and was immediately
impressed by the boxer citing his power
and skill as reasons for including him
he was pretty confident in Tyson's
abilities and who wouldn't be especially
considering he was probably watching
this so Nintendo signed Tyson to a
three-year contract making him the final
boss and punch-out the fighter that
everyone feared in real life was now
standing in between the players and the
end credits it was as close as you could
get to actually getting in the ring with
Tyson and in many ways was a realistic
portrayal of how his matches typically
played out
if you didn't come prepared with
encyclopedia knowledge of all his
attacks you were probably gonna go down
hard and fast Tyson could knock you into
next Tuesday with his one-hit ko
uppercuts or simply jab you to death if
you weren't paying attention and
blocking too much would drain your
stamina quickly allowing Tyson to
swiftly knock you to the floor so you
have to wait
dodge punch repeat every single move you
made had consequences and you had to be
perfect if you stood a chance that beat
him unscathed but over the years people
persisted those that never be Tyson in
the 80s were still trying in the 90s and
2000's and even now in 2017 the
challenge to knock out the former
heavyweight champion of the world still
exists and people are still stepping up
to face him there's even a bar here in
San Francisco that would offer you a
free ball of champagne if you could take
down Mike Tyson giant bomb zone Dan
Reicher took him up on that challenge
and won twice no matter what city you
hail from though it's pretty clear Mike
Tyson was arguably the most feared boxer
of all time but his reign as the champ
as well as the biggest and baddest video
game opponent ever created didn't last
forever by 1990 Nintendo's license to
the Mike Tyson name expired and they
decided not to renew it resulting in the
subsequent re-release of the game
featuring a vanilla ice boss called mr.
dream okay he was basically a reskin of
Tyson's character with different head
and while he could still level you in
the single punch
it just didn't feel the same Nintendo's
decision to leave Mike Tyson behind
might have seemed sudden but it wasn't
out of nowhere
doesn't have the good balance his legs
together is busted landing
[Applause]
after going nearly five years without
losing a single match Tyson was knocked
out by Buster Douglas in the 10th round
of the heavyweight championship fight
the loss was so unlikely that every
casino in Vegas refused to even let
people bet against Tyson well except for
one and the one that Dave gave Douglas
42 to one odds making him a true
underdog a real-life little Mac if you
will in one fell swoop Tyson had lost
the title and eventually Nintendo's
interest in them just as quickly as he
rose to dominance Tyson's troubles both
in the ring and outside of it push them
out of the punch-out series for good
it's been almost 30 years since Nintendo
decide to part ways but Mike Tyson's
punch-out still remains a shining
example of what licensed games can be
and how the delicate nature of celebrity
endorsements are I'm sure every athlete
or celebrity that signs up goes in
knowing that they might not be able to
make a madden like career out of it but
some flail more quickly than others and
in Tyson's case are swiftly assured off
the stage at the slightest hint of
failure controversy and in the year
since Tyson Grace of the cover we've
seen countless games try to give players
the ultimate boxing experience EA's
fight night and knockout Kings series
brought real-life boxers and arenas into
the mix nintendo attempted to bring us
into the future with a new generation of
motion controlled flailing and Mike
Tyson's himself even tried to recapture
some of the magic with his own terrible
boxing game despite the best efforts
from some of the world's most talented
developers there hasn't been a game that
has even come close to matching the
success and ubiquity of Mike Tyson's
punch-out as for myself I never got the
chance to play punch out while Tyson was
still king but for those who did it
meant an opportunity to go one-on-one
with a real-life boss Tyson may have
been an unstoppable force in the ring
but punch out allow the ordinary person
to live out a fantasy they could lay
claim to an impossible feat and show the
world that yes the mighty can fall and
the little max of the world could be the
ones to bring them down
[Music]
hey everyone I hope you had fun watching
this video I know I have a blast making
it and researching all these crazy Mike
Tyson facts but what do you guys think
of them did you ever knock them out
yourselves in the game I'd love to hear
some stories in the comments if you got
any and also if you enjoyed watching
this video consider leaving a like or
even subscribing to our Channel so
thanks for watching and I'll see you all
next time
[Music]